thus the object in its pure determinate
Nisour in the determinate 'no supposed
to constitute its essential being is
overcome just as surely as it was in its
sensuous being from a sensuous being it
turned into a universal but this
Universal sense it originates in the
sensuous is essentially conditioned by
it and hence is not truly a self
identical universality at all but one
afflicted with an opposition for this
reason the universality splits into the
extremes of singular individuality and
universality into the one of the
properties and the also of the free
matters these pure determinate missus
seem to express the essential nature
itself but they are only a being for
self that is burdened with a being for
another since however both are
essentially in a single unity what we
now have is unconditioned absolute
universality and consciousness here for
the first time truly enters the realm of
the understanding
you'll notice now that in section 129
and in 130 Hegel is going to speak of
the understanding and we'll come back to
that in a moment what I would caution
you from right at the very beginning is
automatically reading into that term all
of the conscience that people tend to
associate with it because Hegel was not
just a reader of conch but of many other
philosophers who use that term
understanding or intellect and we'll
come back to that in a moment
but let's start with with what's going
on in this particular section so we're
kind of picking up the pieces at this
point and seeing what we can do to put
Humpty Dumpty of the thing back together
again aren't we so he says the object at
it's pure determinate missus notice the
plural there and it's pure determinacy
x' we might say it's ways of being
determined which are multiple not just
one single determinate Ness but multiple
determinants this is that somehow have
to be coordinated within the scope of
the object in relation to other objects
for the perceiving consciousness says
these are supposed to constitute its
essential being right so we've got these
these properties these free manners
these determinate missus that's supposed
to be what the object really is about
when we're perceiving it that's what we
started with that's what we've been
working our way through that's where
Hegel starting here he says the object
and these were supposed to constitute
its essential being is overcome just as
surely as it was in its sensuous being
so a similar process is happening here
in perception has happened towards the
end of sense certainty we've realized
that the the object of sense certainty
the immediacy of it didn't turn out to
be like that you know we went through
the whole dialectic of the here and
there then the the now you know
time-space universals all those sorts of
things so he says from a sensuous being
it turned into a
Universal but this Universal census
originates in the sensuous since it's
coming about through our processes of
perceiving of experiencing remains as
he's going to say conditioned by it so
you know this is something worth pausing
about for a minute when we think about
our perceptions of things does this ring
true with us do we get our conceptions
of universals at least the universals
that pertain to the perceiving you know
the world that we engage in do we get
those in part through our perception of
things and does that condition them well
you know let's think about as we've done
so long chalk right is this the only way
that chalk and look or is the aspect of
chalk for you and I because we live in a
age of mass-produced mechanical
reproduction is our sense of chalk a
little bit different than it might be
for ancient Romans who also had black
boards with smaller ones and it also
packs tablets right that would be a good
example right there actually of the
thing you know having it's it's
determinacy in part in relation to its
other that its life but isn't the same
thing as we don't write on wax tablets
we don't use extra sketches at least you
know those of us who aren't you know
playing around with them as kids but we
do use truck but we also use say
whiteboards that would be our point of
comparison there are universals that
we're using for a piece of chalk or
chalkboard are conditioned by the
sensuous manifold that we work with them
we are situated you might say Hegel is
noting this this is by the way one of
those places where everyone says
Hegel is so abstract it doesn't take
account of the individual particular he
does in fact but he sees that as part of
the problem so he goes on he says it's
not a truly a self identical
universality
but one afflicted with opposition it
splits it is afflicted with a tendency
to shatter into two sides a side of
universality and a side of singular
individuality now I have placed these
above the one and the also but I don't
want you to think just because I put
them there on the chalkboard you know
you've got you know only so much room
here that they are necessarily connected
in that way there's no reason to think
that the one with its properties is
necessarily the universality and not
actually the singular individuality the
Daniel's talking about here we could
productively read it either way we're
either the one or they also can take on
either of these aspects because there's
so much slippage here in terms of the
universality so he says we have these
extremes singular universality and
individuality and universality the one
of the properties the also of the free
matters we've seen that you know we not
only can see the thing in these
different ways but we're stuck seeing
the thing in these different ways and we
can't seem to unify them we can't seem
to shove them all in the same semantical
or conceptual shoebox and put an end to
cannery so he says these cure
determinate misses seem to express the
essential nature itself right but here's
where we have a transition they are only
a being for self that is burdened with a
being for another and we've seen this
interplay just in the last couple of
paragraphs with this key astok structure
a thing is for itself insofar as it is
for another end is for another insofar
as it is for itself it cannot separate
these two aspects apart from each other
they are different from each other but
yeah they're also in a unity but I wanna
I want to stay here for just a moment
and linger over this language burden the
being for self can't get away from being
for another it would love to
and cut you know consciousness skipping
ahead to the next paragraph
consciousness would love for it to be
nice and simple like that but it isn't
universality we would love this
universality could just be exactly what
we want it to be in what we pretended to
be but at this stage it's not that
remember how we just talked in the last
video about note vindicates necessity in
a certain way of being you don't get
what you want you get what there is and
you're stuck with it so you'd better
figure out what to do with it
that's the same thing that's going on
right here in Hegel is not saying it in
those terms but you could easily read
that in now let's follow this out so
there is a unity between these two right
beating for itself and beating for
another we're going to unified in the
object in the thing in its relation to
other things so what does that mean
Hegel says since they are essentially in
a single unity what we have now is
unconditioned absolute universality
doesn't that sound great absolute
unconditioned universality you can't get
any better than that it's not going to
actually turn out to be stuff but at
least it appears so for the moment but
now absolutely unconditionally ality for
what for the Faculty of the understand
or if you like the Faculty of the
intellect that which takes in the
sensible and make sense of it
sense beyond the sense available from a
purely sensuous position that extracts
concepts out of it that carries out
generalization that operates upon it and
eventually when we get to cut has an
entire manifold the categories of the
understanding which it imposes upon the
content but even if we take count out of
the picture and we just stick say
with the British empiricists or some of
the earlier rationalist that focus on
the intellect or the understanding
what's the upshot of this perception now
is sensuous but what's being extracted
from it is something that's supposed to
be an unconditioned absolute
universality you might have think about
Descartes and meditation - and his
thought experiment and physical
experiment with the wax what is actually
going on there that's the understanding
trying to figure out what is this wax
and he comes up with well it's really
just you know extended substance that's
that's all I can really make of it so
we're going from this play with the
object for perception for the perceiver
for consciousness and now consciousness
is learning something about itself we've
seen consciousness learn something about
itself previously when it dealt with in
this section itself being and also a
medium that took in things through the
various senses and then somehow United
them together in an object what's doing
that is it the common sense or is it
instead the understanding and is the
understanding thereby converting the
sensuous into absolute universality and
overcoming this split
thus the singular being of sense does
indeed vanish in the dialectical
movement of immediate certainty and
becomes universality but it is only a
sensuous universality my meaning has
vanished and perception takes the object
as it is in itself or as a universal as
such singular being therefore emerges in
the object is true singleness as the in
itself out of the one where as a
reflectiveness into self but this is
still a condition being for self
alongside which appears another being
for self the universality which is
opposed to and conditioned by singular
being but these two contradictory
extremes are not merely alongside each
other but in a single unity or in other
words of the defining characteristic
common to both that is being for self is
burdened with opposition generally that
is it is at the same time not a being
for self the sophistry of perception
seeks to save these moments from their
contradiction and it seeks to lay hold
on the truth by distinguishing between
the aspects by sticking to the also and
to the insofar and finally by
distinguishing the UH nacelle aspect
from an essence which is opposed to it
but these expedience instead of warding
off deception in the process of
apprehension prove themselves on the
contrary to be quite empty and the truth
which is supposed to be won by this
logic of the perceptual process proves
to be in one in the same respect the
opposite of itself and thus to have as
its essence a universality which is
devoid of distinctions and a terminus
section 130 might be titled the
sophistry of perception order might be
titled you can't have your cake and eat
it too and you can't even have that how
are we going to get there well we see
him talking about the singular being of
sense and it vanishes he says or gives
way to universality which is then taken
in by perception right but this is a
sensuous universality and we've seen
some of the problems with that but a lot
of the problems are actually below the
surface right here it looks like finally
we're getting something that we can
latch on to it's the universal just like
we were finishing up with in sense
certainty maybe we've traversed the same
path just in a more sophisticated way at
a higher level maybe now we're ready to
move into something else
Hegel always has a surprise for you
here's how he says it my meaning that is
the mining mining the intending the the
singular has vanished because I no
longer can talk or focus on the singular
being of sense because as it turns out
it's not there there isn't anything to
really grasp like that it always turns
out to be harnessed and to be condensed
into this universality perception
perception can grasp that perception
takes the object in itself in its
determinate mode of being how it is it
grasps it as itself he says at the
universal and as such so what happens in
singular being therefore emerges in the
object as true singleness singular being
emerges in the object of perception as
true singleness which is actually to be
a universal the universal is what really
is single
unified so he goes on and he says the in
itself of the one or a reflectiveness
into self but this is still a condition
being for self alongside which appears
another being for self so what we have
here is we think this is what we're
giving and actually instead I should put
two arrows this is what we get instead
what's above the board isn't really
what's below the board and what's below
the board is what matters and now we
have this whole complex where we have
two being for self the being for self of
the unity or the the seen you linearity
and the singular thing that allows it to
be a singular thing and now it's not
just opposed to another singular thing
it's opposed to the universal itself
that makes sense out of what it actually
is so this piece of chalk becomes
opposed to the for itself of the
universality chalk Ness charka T
whatever we want to call it and what
does that mean that means that it's it's
burdened again like we saw in the
previous passage there is a splitting
that's taking place here there's an
opposition that it cannot extricate and
free itself of this turned out to be a
mirage so he goes on and he says it's a
condition being for itself alongside
which appears another being for itself
the universality which is opposed to and
condition by singular being we know the
chocolates through the cha we know the
chalk through a sharpness both of them
condition each other neither one of them
it is where the entirety of what's going
on lies no matter how badly perception
wants that to be the case so here's
where he is going to say these two
contradictory extremes are not merely
alongside each other but also in a
single unity and what is that single
unity it lies in the fact that being for
self is not being for self and not being
for self is being for self these things
are unified in relation to each other so
he says
being for self is burdened with
opposition at the same time it's a not
being for some that doesn't mean that it
stops being being for self but it means
that it also is not what it is
I know that sounds rather tricky so I'm
going to say it one more time
so you can wrap your head around it
being for self the relation to itself
that makes it the kind of object that it
is it is at the same time a not being
for itself not what it is the the
relation itself to self is not what it
is is not what can constitute the thing
as being this perfect finished sensuous
universality that was supposed to
represent the singular being a sense
that hopefully that makes sense so he
calls this the sophistry of perception
and what is softest softest tree has
long history with with philosophy as a
discipline sophistry Plato identified as
not being what it pretended to be in a
certain way sophistry it's being for
self it's self understanding of what it
was doing doesn't turn out to be the way
that it is all you need to do is read
the Republic book one or gorgeous or
several of the other dialogues to figure
that out right because they can't
actually stand up to the dialectic that
Plato brings to bear on them when we
talk about sophistry we mean something
that passes for wisdom but can't
actually hold it's it's it's a position
when it's being challenged it has to
shift its brown over and over and over
again
that's what Hegel describes happening
here I'm not going to put all the other
stuff up on board because there's too
many different distinctions to talk
about and you can go back you can read
back through the previous passages the
previous paragraphs and see exactly what
he's talking about here we started out
with you know talking about these
aspects sticking to the also in the in
so far finally by distinguishing between
the honest
aspect from an essence which is opposed
to it then he says these expedience said
of warding off deception in the process
of apprehension instead of allowing
perception to say I've purified myself
of all this d'etre test that was getting
me confused or leading me astray before
it's just showing that perception
doesn't actually know quite what it's
doing he says these expedience prove
themselves on the contrary to be quite
empty
so what do we get we drive from this
over here to having some sort of essence
but it's an essence that's lacking
distinctions won't achieve and
determination which tintype exactly the
sort of things that we need in order to
make sense out of this right so what
good is this essence that lacks
distinctions and determinate us it's not
very good at all
and is it's going to trial it's not
really even in essence but the ads with
the sophistry of perception the
sophistry is we're gonna see a good old
common sense is going to lead us into
according to Hegel
these empty abstractions of a singleness
and universality opposed to it and of an
essence that is linked with something uh
nacelle a non-essential aspect that
which is necessary all the same these
are powers whose interplay as a
perceptual understanding walk'n called
sound common sense this sound common
sense which takes itself to be a solid
realistic consciousness is in the
perceptual process only the play of
these abstractions generally it is
always at its poorest where it fancies
itself to be the richest bandied about
by these vacuous essences thrown into
the arms first of wanting and then of
the other and striving by its sophistry
to hold fast and affirm alternately
first one of these essences and then the
directly opposite one it sets itself
against the truth and holds the opinion
that philosophy is concerned only with
mental entities as a matter of fact
philosophy does have to do with them to
recognizing them as the pure essences
the absolute elements and powers but in
doing so recognizes them in their
specific determinate nacelle and is
therefore master over them whereas
perceptual understanding or sound common
sense takes them for the truth and is
led on by them from one error to another
it does not itself become conscious that
it is simple essentiality z' of this
kind that holds sway over it but fancies
that it has always to do with wholly
substantial material and content justice
sent certainty is unaware that the empty
abstraction of pure being is its essence
but it is in fact these essentiality z--
within which perceptual understanding
runs to and fro through every kind of
material and content they are the
cohesive power and mastery over that
content and they alone are what the
sensuous is as essence for consciousness
they are what determines the relations
of the sensuous to it and it is in them
that the process of perception and of
its truth runs its course this chorus a
perpetual alternation of determining
what is true and then setting aside this
determining constitutes strictly
speaking the steady everyday life and
activity of perceptual consciousness a
conscious
which fancies itself to be moving in the
realm of truth it advances
uninterruptedly to the outcome in which
all these essential essentiality x' or
determinations are equally set aside but
in each single moment it is conscious
only of this one determinist as the
truth and then in turn of the opposite
one
it does indeed suspect their unassign xi
ality and to save them from the danger
threatening them it resorts to the
sophistry of asserting to be true what
it has itself just declared to be untrue
what the nature of these untrue essences
is really trying to get perceptual
understanding to do it is to bring
together and thereby supersede the
thoughts of these non entities the
thoughts of that universality and
singular being of also and one of the
essentiality that is necessarily linked
to the unofficial moment in and of an
unofficial moment that yet is necessary
but the understanding struggles to avoid
doing this by resorting to insofar as
into the various aspects or by making
itself responsible for one thought in
order to keep the other one isolated as
the true one but the very nature of
these abstractions brings them together
of their own accord it is sound common
sense that is the prey of these
abstractions which spin it round and
round in their whirling circle when
common sense tries to make them true by
at one time making itself responsible
for their untruth while that another
time it calls their deceptiveness
assemblance of the unreliability of
things and separates what is on a set
what is essential from what is necessary
to them yet supposedly uh nacelle
holding the former to their be the truth
as against the latter when it does this
it does not secure them their truth but
convicts itself of untruth
with this quite long paragraph section
131 Hegel is bringing the section
perception to a close now the length of
this is a little bit deceptive there's
perhaps you might say a bit less going
on there than the length might suggest
but he's he's bringing everything
together and he's convicting a way of
thinking about things of its
insufficiency of its sophistry of its
inadequacy and what he's going to be
bashing here is what he calls the
perceptual understanding or as many
people are going to call it sound common
sense now what's he going on about with
all this let's let's take a look at what
he says there's all these as he calls
empty abstractions singleness
universality that's opposed to an
essence that's linked with something an
essential and non-essential aspect was
necessary all the same says these are
powers whose interplay is the perceptual
understanding and this sound
common-sense takes itself as he says to
be something solid something that is
getting to the heart of things that is
grasping reality as as it truly is so he
says what's really going on though is
it's just a play of those abstractions
it's always at his poorest where it
fancies itself the richest so perceptual
understanding thinks that it is grasping
what's going on here in the sensuous
particular things and really all is it's
getting hold of are these categories
over here or particular eyes Asians of
them but any case it treats them as
abstract it does not grasp them as they
are and thinks that it's grasping their
essence when really it's not
so he says bandied about it by these
vacuous essences there's this constant
interplay where perceptual understanding
is not getting what it really desires or
you might say that the person the
consciousness is not getting what he or
she desires through the perceptual
understanding so perceptual
understanding is going to say well how
about this
well okay now how about this over here
sort of like a shop clerk that can't
give you the right product and they just
keep up a pattern going back and forth
and back and forth suggesting different
alternatives so he says as a matter of
fact you know what's going to happen
here is philosophy is going to be seen
by good old common sense as only dealing
with these mental entities only dealing
with these abstractions and Hegel says
you know what that's actually partly
right because a dialectical philosophy a
genuine philosophy would be dealing with
them but it would be dealing with them
in a very different way this philosophy
in philosophy of the understanding as
Hegel is going to call it in so many
other places will take its cues from
these and allow these to dominate it
will not attempt to impose some sort of
structure upon it this is one way in
which you can say this is very
unconscious because the content
understanding or as we know imposes
categories right but those categories
are pretty fixed in a Hegelian dialectic
'el system philosophy takes these and
masters them it makes them its own and
it places them in the proper relation
which it has between that and the
sensuous particular things which we saw
condition the universals condition the
essences and in turn are conditioned by
them so it treats them as determinate
essences not just as abstract essences
if we go on a little bit further he's
coming back to this complaint that he
has he says that the the perceptual
understanding runs to an to and fro
through every kind of material and
content in these essentiality so it's
trying to grasp this object an object
this object an object
trying to make sense out of all of them
but he says they are the Cui's of power
and mastery over that content they alone
are what the sensuous is as an essence
for consciousness they are what
determines the relations of the sensuous
to it and it is in them of the process
of perception and of its truth runs its
course the problem is
this is a perpetual he says alternating
of alternation of determining what is
true and then setting aside this
determining so it can never find a fixed
point to settle down on even though it
promises us and promises itself that it
is indeed finding these fixed points if
angle is right then anybody calls
philosophy of the understanding is
always going to be an incomplete
philosophical perspective it will appear
for a while as if it's taking everything
in whether it's a Cartesian philosophy
or a humanity or even a conscience you
know what some of the Neo captions made
of Kant when they took a more positive
astern with that but it's never going to
deliver us what we actually want from
philosophy which is in part to
understand what the hell is coming
between these and how does consciousness
actually take all of these in together
so he says you know what happens is that
the understanding struggles to avoid
bringing all these together in some sort
of coherent way by resorting to the
insofar as into the various aspects or
making it responsible for one thought in
order to keep the other one isolated as
the true one but he says the very nature
of these abstractions brings them
together of their own accord now what
does that mean these sorts of
determinations when we actually let them
do what they want to do when we allow
them to develop dialectically they show
us their connections to each other
that's why we can do a phenomenology of
this that's why we're at stuck with a
philosophy of the understanding that's
why we can observe as conscious beings
the process through which this occurs
because they have a sort of agency to
them they develop in relation to each
other only an adequate philosophy is
going to grasp that sound common sense
he says is the prey of these
abstractions would spin it round and
round and there
whirling circle when common sense tries
to make them true by at one time making
itself responsible for their untruth
when it says I will take the untruth on
to me and say there's no untruth in
there then they turn around and they
show that there's actually some untruth
there another another time it calls
their deceptiveness a semblance of the
unreliability of things and if that's
the case then sound common-sense isn't
going to make any progress either so
what we have here is a kind of impasse
or Aequorea and not being able to go
further but the reason we can't go
further is because we're relying on this
now could it be that this isn't fully
understood that the relation to itself
has not been developed fully and that
this could be more than just sound
common sense that's what we're going to
see tackled in the next section which is
called force and the understanding but
that's going to require a shift of
perspective to take place which is going
to lead us into this